he's going to do the tanahanka with his
hands
he's got to push them fingers out
all right
since he used to say
that
[Laughter]
he's got to be it's got to hold water
so you'll see it's by pushing your
fingers that won't help because of uh
you've still got the gaps
so that's when we say Tana Hank is
really difficult
it seems simple you know what I don't
know why I'm doing this really at least
why the sense he keeps saying it's so
important he's got to make you'll notice
with cytosensity you know look at the
videos he doesn't have flat hands he has
them slightly up
but in this part in this part
so
poor Michael's work trying to work out
all angles and how he makes this pull
but there is a bit of water in there now
move that out a little bit all right so
so you've got to not cramp your hand
you've got to have your hand open but as
you
as you do that you see I don't know if
you can see it but I'm making
a pool
all right so this look this won't take
water will it
this yeah
yeah this takes water
so
um
I don't often
I don't often go to that sort of bother
with them playing games or sale or do
anything but I just want to show you
what how difficult Hannah hinker is
all right
so you're coming here this shape this
shape here I don't know if you can see
that those who can see the ball the pole
is made
I don't go here and then sort of start
to
do this
so here I go one
coal is now made and I come here
all right you see both hands they would
hold they would hold water
all right something I've never taught
before but I keep seeing lots of
different kind of hangers and people
either do that or do that
but what you're looking for is a pole
without tension a pole that is created
without tension all right so we'll try a
little more and I'd just like you to
look there because you know you might
sort of say well I think that's right if
I say to you will it hold water
I don't know why since you he didn't
have to say it very often but he he did
one day said
that this should be able to hold water
okay